et pour en parler nous sommes avec
gérald ollivier journaliste franco
américain bonsoir général de olivier
merci d'être avec nous vos côtés cécile
cau kemoko professeur en civilisation
américaine à l'université de versailles
bonsoir à vous également merci d'être là
donc c'est un procès historique qui
s'est ouvert il ya plus d'une heure à
washington un procès dénoncé par les
avocats de trump qui parle d'une mise en
scène politique ce procès gerald de
olivier il est historique ou symbolique
plutôt écouté il est historique puisque
aucun président avant donald trump n'a
été destituée deux fois dans un même
mandat ni deux fois tout court
maintenant il est symbolique également
pour deux raisons parce que d'abord on
en connaît l'issue les démocrates savent
qu'ils ont 50 voix et ils ont peut être
récupérée où ils vont récupérer cinq
voix chez les républicains mais ça ne
suffira pas pour voter la condamnation
du président puisqu'il faudrait un vote
à la majorité des deux tiers
donc on sait que donald trump sortira je
dirais acquitté de ce procès mais ce qui
se déroule en ce moment même et le
premier débat qui est en train de
marquer l'ouverture de ce procès est
assainie significatif puisque ce débat
est autour de la constitutionalité même
de la procédure
je rappelle que la destitution est
utilisé pour renvoyer un président en
place
en l'occurrence donald trump n'est plus
en place depuis bientôt trois semaines
et donc la prod la procédure n'a pas
véritablement de finalité est d'ailleurs
notons qu'un procès en destitution doit
se dérouler selon la constitution sous
la présidence du président de la cour
suprême qui est le juge john roberts et
john roberts a décliné cette présidence
a décliné cette fonction de par le fait
même que la constitutionnalité du
processus est mise en doute
alors justement c'est si le coquet et
mokoko pour rebondir en ce que disait
sur ce que disait gérald olivier peut-on
tout simplement mettre en accusation un
ancien président américain redevenu
simples citoyens depuis les faits il est
vrai ça ne s'est jamais produit par le
passé
cependant on peut citer le cas d'un
ancien ministre de la guerre qui au tout
début des années 1870 a effectivement
été destitué de son de sa charge
après avoir quitté ses fonctions à la
suite d'une procédure de dup richmond et
de destitution donc s'étend aussi un
signal qui est envoyé au futur président
de la république américaine pour leur
dire qu'ils ne peuvent pas utiliser les
dernières semaines où les derniers jours
de leur mandat pour remettre en cause
les institutions et éventuellement
appelé à des insurrections armées
alors j'ai un l'olivier à nous le disait
il ya quelques instants le procès a
finalement peu de chances d'aboutir
gérald olivier quel intérêt alors de ce
procès tuer politiquement donald trump
peut-être pour les démocrates
c'est en effet l'un des objectifs parce
que l'idée ce serait d'empêcher donald
trump de se présenter à tous nouveaux
postes électifs
y compris bien entendu l'élection
présidentielle de 2024 rappelons tout de
même que pour parvenir à cet objectif il
faudrait aux démocrates de vote
c'est à dire qu'il faudrait d'une part
voté la condamnation du président encore
une fois c'est très très peu probable et
les mêmes acquis que ce ne sera pas le
cas et au cas où l'on ait cette
condamnation il faudrait ensuite voter
une seconde fois cette fois à la
majorité simple pour priver donald trump
de ses droits de citoyen et notamment le
droit de tenir tous postes électifs à
l'avenir donc l'objectif initial des
démocrates était bien entendu de tuer
donald trump en tant qu'animal politique
l'objectif secondaire malgré tout c'est
aussi de diviser le parti républicain de
forcer à certain nombre d'élus
républicains à prendre une position ne
soit pour défendre donald trump
au risque de se placer en position je
dirais paradoxal vis-à-vis de la
constitution soit de lui rester fidèle
et donc de continuer à profiter du
soutien de la base de la troupe
rappelons qu'aujourd'hui
donald trump est simple si
voyez un cercle mais il est aussi en
vérité l'homme qui a la main sur leur
parti républicain avec un nombre de
supporters extrêmement important et
extrêmement dévouée à sa cause et il est
très difficile aujourd'hui pour les
républicains de se prononcer contre
donald trump
même si du côté des démocrates
l'objectif du procès était de favoriser
cette division est de la porter au
premier plan cécile cau kemoko avec ce
procès d'un tram joue-t-il son avenir
politique si tenté qu'il ait encore des
ambitions politiques
il est très certainement en cours des
on ne peut pas dire étant donné qu'on
sait déjà l'issue du procès qu' il soit
mort et enterré on en est encore loin
la question centrale va être au delà des
futurs procès éventuel qui lui seront
intentées notamment probablement par
l'état de géorgie mais aussi par la
justice new yorkaise pour une accusation
d'évasion fiscale ce sera la question de
savoir s'il aura encore des financements
pour de futures campagnes électorales
l'argent reste absolument le nerf de la
guerre pour toute campagne politique
américaine
donc s'il est encore en vogue parmi les
grands donateurs du parti républicain
les autres républicains dans leur grande
majorité ont vont tout intérêt à
continuer à le soutenir
si en revanche il devient toxique aussi
au plan financier il ya fort à parier
que son étoile pourra pas lire mais pour
l'instant c'est encore loin
on est encore loin de pouvoir tirer ce
genre de projection alors pour le moment
donné 30 restent silencieux il ne s'est
pas encore exprimé le procès s'est
ouvert il ya une heure quinze dont le
rappel en son absence gerald des
oliviers
la stratégie qu'il va poursuivre donald
trump parce qu'elle est important qu'il
a peut-être intérêt à faire profil bas
lors de ces audiences ne pas se faire
trop remarquer de son côté il ne
participera pas au procès c'est à dire
que les démocrates avaient demandé ce
qu'ils viennent qui viennent témoigner
sous serment
il y avait même proposé de faire un
témoignage à huis clos pour des raisons
de sécurité nationale
ses avocats ont refusé en refuser et de
la drogue ne sera pas présent à aucun
moment de l'audience maintenant ses
avocats vont dire trois choses si vous
voulez la première c'est qu'ils vont en
effet poursuivre cet argument selon
lequel cette procédure est
inconstitutionnelle 1le les événements
du 6 janvier et n ont pas se sont
produits non pas à l'incitation de
donald trump
mais avait été préméditée planifiée à
lavancia certain nombre d'éléments qui
permettent de soutenir cette thèse là à
partir du moment où l'événement était
prémédité dassa disculpe donald trump de
toute responsabilité
et puis d'un troisièmement ils vont dire
que le discours présidentiel est protégé
par le premier amendement est que dans
ses propos d'un hâle trump n'a pas été
plus violent que beaucoup d'autres
leaders y compris des démocrates très
récemment et il ya un certain nombre
d'exemples
je rappelle que l'an passé aux états
unis il y a eu énormément d'émeutes
suite à la mort de georges flood et que
ces émeutes qui parfois ont visé des
gouvernements des bâtiments
gouvernementaux ont été soutenues voire
même encouragé par un certain nombre
d'élus démocrates et il est possible que
les avocats de donald trump présente les
propos qui ont été tenus à cette époque
et démontre que ceux du président était
beaucoup moins incitatif que cela alors
cécile coquet mon concours on l'a dit
donald trump silencieux qui ne sera pas
présent à son procès
qui est censuré entre guillemets sur les
réseaux sociaux ça veut dire quoi que
les 30 pistes vont faire entendre leur
voix pour aller en soutien alors ancien
champion c'est encore et toujours le
champion du parti républicain qui n'a
pas vraiment d'autre leader à proposer
au peuple américain et qui va continuer
à surfer sur cette même vague
rappelons que le tea party est née en
2008 et il a trouvé sans son leader son
incarnation en la personne de donald
trump donc politiquement les soutiens de
donald trump vont continuer à tous les
niveaux de s'exprimer que ce soit au
niveau de l'électorat d'un niveau local
mais aussi d'ores et déjà pour se
présenter face à tous les sénateurs et
représentants félon qui auront voté avec
les démocrates pour les pitchouns de
donald trump donc là la guerre pour pour
l'establishment du parti républicain
finalement est pratiquement remporté
davance pour le camp d'être en piste et
il reste à savoir aussi combien de temps
trump restera banni des réseaux sociaux
gérald olivier c'est procès il est très
attendu par les américains il être suivi
en masse écouter les chaînes de
télévision leur transmettent pour
l'instant on s'attend à quelque chose
d'assez cours en fait c'est un procès
qui tourne là il a été voulu par les
démocrates il a été voulu par nancy
pelosi et vous avez eu un reportage pour
les souligné juste avant de nous
interroger
mais il embarrasse beaucoup de joe biden
parce que joe bar et john préfèreraient
que l'on prête attention notamment à sa
loire sur un plan de relance dans le
cadre de l'aide
suite à la pandémie de coded or le sénat
pour l'instant et bien se trouve
monopolisé par ce procès pour au moins
on va dire cinq jours parce que la
procédure qui est envisagée devrait
durer à peu près cinq jours d'une
certaine façon c'est une distraction et
c'est un rappel de la de l'ombre de
trump qui vient à nouveau planer sur le
début de la pré
y danse de joe biden le président lui
même le président en exercice actuel
aurait plutôt souhaité que l'on passe à
autre chose et que ce procès n'ait pas
lieu
par contre il va certainement pour
l'instant intéresser des américains je
sais pas si ça va durer parce que comme
nous l'avons souligné
en effet on connaît l'issue de ce procès
quand vous connaissez la fin du film ce
qui s'y passait beaucoup intéressant
merci en tout cas à tous les deux on
suivra avec attention
il devrait durer une semaine ce procès
gérald olivier cécile cau kemoko merci
d'avoir été en direct sur rt france